hi everybody so I'm Karen green for
those of you who are new to this
afternoon and the graphic novels
librarian and I'm the co-organizer along
with Danny finger off and Jeremy Dalbir
in the in the doorway there just one
little thing to say is if you didn't get
a program there on the table outside
there's also a sign-up sheet if you'd
like to be on our mailing list for
future comics events at columbia and the
panel will last an hour there'll be a
half hour for book buying and book
signing by our authors and panelists in
the hallway outside so without further
ado I will turn this over to moderator
Danny finger off thank you Karen thank
you everybody oh nice crowd I just want
to say a few things before we start the
panel and before we make introductions a
the since it is in New York panel I have
a PowerPoint that's got a lot of slides
I have a bunch of questions but I
encourage crosstalking interrupting and
the complaining ok that's it is a New
York panel so let's do it right so if I
haven't asked the thing you wanted me to
ask or if I haven't asked it soon enough
or just about anything you know so
that's that's that's one they want to
make clear you may have noticed in the
program that the panel was dedicated to
the memory of Jerry Robinson who we lost
in December we lost unfortunately a good
number of comics luminaries in the past
year and the reason was singling Jerry
out as he has Jerry went to Columbia and
so we thought that since this was
happening at this university so it's
certainly not intended as a slide to any
of the other wonderful talent
that we lost and you know that's the
Jerry Columbia connection so if anybody
was wondering while your personal
favorite may not have been mentioned
starting on the left on my left is al
jaffee
al al story has taken him from Georgia
to Lithuania to New York City where he
attended the High School of Music and
Art the first graduating class I believe
his comics career began in will eyes
news studio in the 1940s where he
created inferior man he also worked for
Stanley producing comic books like Ziggy
p silly seal Patsy Walker superrabbit
etc in the 50s Jaffe was also involved
with Harvey Kurtzman's to post mad
magazines Trump and humbug but moved to
med upon their demise where he has
worked as a freelancer ever since he
created the mad fold in in 1964 still
drawing it for every single issue of man
and also snappy answers to stupid
questions and I'm sure I'll get some
snappy answers to some of my stupid
questions I'll be disappointed if I
don't all told he has written and
illustrated about fifty books current
publications include the collected tall
tales the Med folding collection 1964 to
2010 and his original illustrations for
the recent biography al Jaffee's made
life by Mary Lou Weisman who's next miss
Lasko gross is the author and
illustrator of Fantagraphics books a
mess of everything name on a book lists
top 10 graphic novels of the year the
follow-up to the yalsa nominated escape
from special currently her work is
featured in The Show graphic details
confessional comics by Jewish women at
the achieve University Museum through
april fifteenth and in henny a
serialized adventure for the comiXology
house of twelve iphone app dean has bo
is an Emmy award-winning artist who
created the Eisner Award nominated Billy
dogma and illustrated for HBO's bored to
death Dino has drawn many superhero and
semi-autobiographical comic books and
the superhero or semi-autobiographical
as well and graphic novels from major
publishers including collaborations with
jonathan lethem Harvey Pekar Jonathan
Ames in Vera Lok Lak PES ok and recently
with the tim hall on the last mortician
for tour com he also helped pioneer
personal web comics we mention of
activate for new Billy dogma and other
cool multimedia projects and profiles
visit Tripp citynet a Brooklyn filtered
literary art salon and finally I did the
wrong order answer okay and of course I
who's got Tracy whites this is
embarrassing it was got who's got a
program with Tracy yeah I got it Tracy
white writes and draws comics she's the
creator of the Ignatz nominated
autobiographical webcomic traced an
ongoing series started in 1996 which was
adapted for the oxygen TV network so
Tracy's actually in between Al and Dean
I got my counting mixed up she's the
author of how I made it to 18 a graphic
novel white is also an adjunct professor
nye is interactive telecommunications
program at the Tisch School of the Arts
where she finds interact teachers
interactive comics and storytelling and
her website is traced calm so we're
looking the first the first slide here
is from Will Eisner Athene sent to the
heart of the storm and the name of the
panel is New York is breeding ground
which has sort of a science fiction kind
of creepy feel to it but what it's our
way of talking about people who either
grew up and went to school in New York
and how that affected their artistic
vision or people who were so eager to
get the hell out of where they were and
come to New York and how it affected
that so this is Aizen his rendition of
himself as a child drawing the spirit of
st. Louis Lindbergh's plane for for his
friends or maybe for his enemies so they
wouldn't beat him up but he was the
typical neighborhood artist I'm going to
go through some history here and then as
I say feel free to interject I'll get
the actual questions or or not they
is the Art Students League where a lot
of comics folks went to school this is
pride Institute or I know that Miss was
eager to get out of Boston and come here
to go there and this is DeWitt Clinton
High School in the Bronx where an
astonishing number of creative and
accomplished people not just in comics
but in like every field Lerner and Loewe
Rodgers and Hammerstein James Baldwin
Fats Waller dan shore okay i will pick
it up Bob Kane Bill Finger who created
Batman Erwin Hazen there with Gertrude
Berg who co-created Dondi Stanley who
will get to his creations in a bit will
eisner who was a sort of the ultimate
New York comics creator of course
created the spirit here's some spirit
material that is pretty new yorky even
though it's called central city and
here's the High School of Music and Art
where these two guys went to high school
on the left is a mr. al jaffee and on
the right is wolf Eisenberg and you may
know is a will elder so al what is it
with these new york high schools why
what why do they widened what in New
York High School's breed as the panel
for that so many unique creative talents
well I guess there was a fungus
somewhere I mean you think it was just
geographic that oh here in the center of
whatever or was there something
Oh educational system to help most was
that the comic book industry the
publishers started in New York and it
would just was a very natural thing for
those of us who are graduating from the
Great Depression to find easy work as
cartoonist because you know those of us
who would like to do cart would have
liked to have done cartooning and in the
newspapers you getting into those places
was near impossible but the burgeoning
comic book industry had open arms I mean
I I walked into will eisner 'he's studio
just with a little but with this yeah
with this silly drawing and i didn't
have a script to go with it I didn't
have anything else so just the name of
this character pardon was the name of
this character uh the name of the
character was inferior man
he was the defender of the inept and
pardon inferior man is not on that now
this is all very very man is on that
that's that's what it became yo so how
did you convince her will to well this
is this was kind of a I don't think it
worked because it wasn't Imperial will
like the idea he was intrigued by I
guess the fact that it was one of the
early satirical attempts at making fun
of Superman and but I didn't have
anything to go with it and he said all
right we'll put my original idea with by
day inferior man was an accountant and
he decided that was not exciting enough
he said let's put him in the army
because you know the war was on at that
time and will will have his adventures
in the army well I had not been in the
Army yet and I had no idea what life in
the Army was like so writing scripts
were for it was sort of alien to me and
just it sort of didn't go anywhere
because it was a bad combination so it's
that sort of i think died a slow death
and and as far as working with Eisner I
mean what what did you I know you talked
about things you learned from him and
working with him I know it was only
briefly but will eisner was a brilliant
writer and in my view a brilliant artist
of the time I don't know how he would
stack up today but
we I think my friends and I all
worshiped the spirit we thought it was
you know the cleverest thing to come
down the pike and it had a it had a
logic to it that didn't exist with
Batman and and Superman we couldn't
figure out how Superman was flying
whereas will in Will Eisner 'he's work
everything was logically worked out but
i I just I can't say enough about lil
Eisner I think he was brilliant no no
Dean and the Tracy you both went to high
school in New York and I have your work
later on coming up but how did that have
had it being native new yorkers impact
your work did you uh did you love being
in New York early dying to get the hell
out I mean I like New York until I was a
teenager and just you know wanted to do
whatever my family wasn't doing but and
be wherever they weren't but I think in
terms of storytelling when you grow up
in New York you know most people are
walking around they're not in cars and
so you start seeing all these people and
you see all these different people and
they're not like your family and you can
go downtown and remember going to soho
for the first time and I was like this
is a different world i grew up on 90th
street and east end and I just you know
you don't have to go on an airplane you
could just go in the subway and every
day when I was going to school I was on
a bus and i was looking at people and
it's like you see the same people every
day everyone takes the same seat and i
watch this guy remember over the course
of a year getting hair plugs and i
remember sitting across from him every
day and watching you know watching them
be like a few more
and and just thinking you know like what
is this guy's life and does that hurt
and you know all these questions were
coming up in my mind and what's his
story and I just think that you know and
now as an adult I walk behind people and
I hear their phone conversations I'm
like what are they saying on the other
end you know and what are they doing and
I'm constantly taking photographs of
people from behind because I'm
interested you know I don't want to I
don't want them to know I have taken
their photographs but I'm kind of
interested what are people wearing
because for my comics and I just think
when you grow up here especially as a
kid and you see so many people walking
around you you can't help but wonder
what everyone's story is and I think
that that just gets your imagination
going I mean that that's that's such a
weird question is like you know what
makes New York story I I you know I I
too went to music in our high school not
with a little bit later and it was an
art school you know and and there I know
how many arts schools are in the nation
but it seems to be in the major cities
and major cities often are melting pots
of sorts and they yield stories like
what you're talking about and you have
access to these things I think what
makes my stories New York stories is
that i was born in New York Hospital I'm
a native New Yorker oh really oh and but
i think it's it's what you know as a
cartoonist and a storyteller i'm just in
some way reporting what's around me you
know and recording and reporting so
that's what makes them new york stories
you know by default listen you know I
worked with Harvey Pekar a lot and he's
responsible for a lot of Cleveland
stories you know the thing that I
learned most from working with Harvey is
that he observed just like what you're
talking about it and observation is key
to telling stories so that's what makes
you know in grains these stories with
their geography now miss you you come
from Boston which is not exactly a small
town but
well what we getting away from and
getting too i'm sorry i was gonna say i
haven't grown up in the suburbs of
massachusetts where it was very
homogenous you know it was like white
liberal jewish but homogeneous in that
yeah and very dome and all the things
that my fellow panelist have been
talking about are the reasons why i was
so desperate to move to New York and why
ultimately graduated high school early
so I could come and live here experience
that and it is really good for your
storytelling because you can't avoid
exciting and interesting encounters with
strange and smelly people and you said
you'd only applied to Pratt you had no
plan B those I didn't I just I wanted to
go to Pratt I had heard that it was a
great school for cartooning which it's
not but I'd heard I should have gone to
do with Clinton and I saw that's where I
wanted to go because I was like I want
to be a cartoonist that's the place and
I didn't really and in hedge my bets I
just went for it with a really lousy
portfolio luckily it all worked out
Molly okay so I'm gonna return to the
history i'll quickly through it but
because this guy is a native New Yorker
Jules Feiffer who went on like alt or
worked for Eisner this is a famous story
called ten minutes that I actually
attributed to eyes until I was giving a
talk about it here at Columbia and Jules
is in the audience and said I wrote that
when I was 17 so but that's got a real
New York feel that kind of Eisner fight
for that candy and soda store and then
we go back to Al's classmates from from
a music and art the gentleman on the
bottom a tangled up in the ladder is a
wheel elder and then al is the guy with
the words al jaffee above his head
harvey kurtzman was also in school with
them and this is a spoof of some famous
and what do they see what what what ad
is this spoofing i break apart is this
is this picture is a spoof of a famous a
door oh yeah it appeared in Trump right
but what was it spoofing well it was
a pretentious it was trying to capture
the pretentiousness that other
legitimate magazines used to advertise
themselves and so we thought we would
you know we would do the same thing I
think this was a table of contents if I
the empty space on the right it probably
contained a table of contents which
obviously was nothing and then these
these same guys before al drawing them
started this magazine which led which
had a certain New York sensibility at
kind of I think I think Kurtzman and
would put every building in New York in
in the back there and then at a certain
point you started how did the foldings
come about al how did the how did the
idea for the fold in come about how did
it come about how did it come about well
if if you have the patience for this
tedious story I was casting about to
come up with an idea for mad because
that's what freelance people do to make
a living and I i surrounded myself with
fancy magazines playboy National
Geographic Life magazine and I noticed
at that particular time that a lot of
them had very fancy full colorful doubts
and I thought there must be an idea here
somewhere format and of course the
natural thing that occurred to me was
that if they have big fancy full-color
expensive fold outs mad would have a
cheap black and white fold in
and so I did it as a one-shot gag
figuring you know this thing doesn't
have any legs at all and mainly because
when I approached the editor Al fealty
and I said al you're not going to buy
this idea i think it's it's funny in
itself but you're not going to buy
because it mutilates the magazine and he
was intrigued ran into the bill Gaines's
office came out and said Bill wants to
go with it he said if the kid mutilates
the magazine or buy a second one for his
collection so by default I got a job and
and that's lasted partner that's that's
a job that's lasted to the present day I
mean in color and everything yes since
nineteen sixty four I can't do the
arithmetic it's a lot or any of you
other panelists inspired by weighted Mad
Magazine fit if anywhere in your car
tuning education I'm uh I read it every
month uh I love the parodies you know
and I love the humor I I think I soon
realized that I wasn't going to be a
funny cartoonist because it's just a
whole other way of thinking you know but
because I was attracted superhero stuff
and then later on the autobio stuff but
uh I loved my Mad Magazine it was like a
perennial every month and was it
quarterly now I guess every seasonal has
gone back to buy monthly or bimonthly
but yeah I mean I I mean alas I have not
read it in years but I I have a fondness
a nostalgia for it um yeah Jack Davis
all those guys are amazing you know
Tracy mrs. was it an influence at all or
I mean I we were talking earlier and I
used to get
every Sunday with my dad and mad was
certainly one of them along with Thor
and Archie and I think sorry I think
that probably an influence in in the way
that New York is an influence as a
background two stories this was just
another thing that that I grew up with
so I the idea of combining words and
images to tell a story was really
natural and it's just one of the many
you know subtle influences I would say
just because you're always reading those
things as a kid and then it seems
natural that that's the way that you
would communicate a story speaking of a
Tracy saying a like don't forget like
the first comics you see that's what you
how you think you should draw things
like when I saw Jack Kirby comics that's
how you do superhero comics or Will
Eisner that's how you draw in new york
city like these guys broke so much
ground and figuring out the certain
visual lexicons and the ways that we
think and see in comics that it's
actually really difficult to break out
of it as your own autor author artist um
saying like there's these perennials out
there these classic ways well they
created it it wasn't classic before that
but you know there are you know or
mythology did you have a sense of it as
a particular New York or New York Jewish
thing well I was in New York I'm reading
it in New York so it's got to be New
York you know that that's the only way I
think you know like I didn't think
academically in any way it's just how I
absorbed it and so that's how I spit it
back out and to me that's you know if
I'm drawing anything you know like
buildings have to have that little kind
of a you know lip on the end and you
draw the windows and some bricks you
know not all the bricks you know you
learn all these little tricks and to me
that's always New York City I'm still
trying to figure out how to
differentiate manhattan from brooklyn
you know without using Empire State
Building you know sometimes I know but
we I mean besides the height you know
there's they're still like a lot of
you're saying you're saying you pick up
a lot of shorthand for ya show the
from reading things like Mad Magazine
and and out there in the wild or the
Boston suburbs did you think oh this is
coming from New York I must know I think
it's Rhonda Lee was actually published
that I got my hands on and I thought it
kind of came up from above I never
really considered the people making it
until I was older my dad used to get men
magazine and give that to me and I
enjoyed the especially the movie
parodies and all the jokes I didn't get
cuz they're just like be subtle the
subtlety of the med Moonves okay just
moving historically quickly through this
is Jerry Robinson who the panel is
dedicated Jerry Jerry with a very
mischievous grin on his face you know
which which might indicate how he came
up with this character and and then a
little New York there is a Jerry to the
cover to new york world's fair so now
you know the world is fair new york
world's fair comics there's the Trylon
and the perejil on door have that harris
fear okay in full detail you would have
to be a new york actually Jarius in new
jersey but he you know he eventually
moved it to the bronx and into Columbia
but like the that's a that's well you
know it is and 96 pages for ten cents
sake now it's free online and then here
is a Ed Sullivan who some of you may
know only as the host of the Beatles but
there's yet sullivan theater or the
Letterman Show is there all these
artists have that sometime in the 60s
did it's Sullivan's portrait because he
was also a powerful Broadway columnist
there's Jerry Robinson on the left in
the middle is Irwin who some of you may
have seen at the panel this morning and
Leonard star is when stars in between
Irwin and and and Jerry
so just an interesting piece of New York
history this steve ditko spider-man very
New York and Ditko was a student of
Jerry's Jack Kirby another person who
kind of established look and feel and
comics there's a Kirby city in the
Fantastic Four with New York in the
background we saw this yesterday there's
Kirby's memories of his childhood
growing up and then street code that was
that we have vostri codes right let me
there's another Street code this is
another person who came desperately in
New York and then I guess just as
desperately got the hell out you can see
tron might not have had the most
positive but the east of it but but the
East Village other was the ultimate New
York underground publication where a lot
of cartoonist got started including Kim
died and this is the office at the East
Village other is drawn by Kim dodge with
the bullpen this main Rodriguez is this
mythology that resonates with any of you
is this uh sorry keep talking um Bob
finger mins in the audience and that was
occurred to me that one of the things
that encouraged me to tell more story
New York stories was a minimum wage
which later on became a beg the question
the collection and Bob's always been a
progenitor of New York stories and
convinced me and I don't know if you
have a any of that as an example up here
at all but I don't but yeah no I mean
Bob a lot of his stuff like encouraged
me like I said to myself to 50 slide 55
okay I don't know Bob wants to go parent
talk about this as well but ok and then
actually been catcher who's sitting over
there is another guy whose stuff that I
like you know reading in the New York
Press was telling all these al ball
stories but the way he drew buildings
and and you know the people you know and
how they you know encompassed you know
the whole story of this new york look
you know they're the different folks
that like I lean towards the funny I was
never I never really were a lot of
underground so I think my underground
comix was like Bob finger mins and and
you know Ben catcher and you know
besides the superhero stuff that you
that you're showing this is this
mythology for anybody else or just al
listen to these guys have any residents
for you the underground guys when they
were doing in the in the 60s and 70s um
I'm not really familiar with this say
this D yeah well this is a family actor
well is it and and I'll these guys these
all these were all guys inspired by you
I but speaking of something inspired by
the underground was oddly enough
realizing there who reinvented himself
and comics with a contract with god he
said oh look you don't have to tell kids
stories you can tell serious stories
with comics and then we get to you know
that the laguardia is that where you
went to school today yeah went to music
and art and I was in the first
graduating class of laguardia high
school I was at the right which is that
building I think I've been a long time
and it was right neck it was behind
Lincoln Center and I think oh my lord is
so gay I don't even know who that person
is on the top right handsome boy
modeling school so wrong that's Larry
O'Neill who fans of comics we know Denny
O'Neil that's his son you know Daniel
Neal writer editor and Larry is now film
backer and he's filming and I've been
hanging out with him lately he's been
come to my studio in writing his next
screen play video so what was it so what
was it like in New York it was
mischievous I don't wish the 80s I have
a lot of scars of my body to prove that
I'm a blood brother with some folks here
in the city you know you were talking
about what you said something
interesting about you would be where
your parents weren't kind of thing I
mean those are the rebellious years you
know that
where you're you know learning Old
English 800 malt liquor and I I abhor
tobacco and smoking and everything I
don't know why we have cigars and I'm
out like what is 14 years old and that
guy's hand on my shoulder because it was
just like a little homage to me and
Larry is actually Josh neufeld han who
also is a cartoonist New Yorker uh I
mean I grew up with a bunch of guys just
like Al did you know we're doing our
comics and then eventually getting to
work with Howard shaken Walt Simonson
built in cabbage in 1985 yeah now that
was that year uh 94 yes so like a year
later I was working with like three hot
dog cartoon yes I like I'll do with eyes
no you didn't apprenticeship how did
that come to be headed well Larry
actually um so Larry was a budding
cartoonist before he became a filmmaker
I've never had the balls to be a
filmmaker I would love to make movies
but you know there's something about
yeah that's old old artwork from way but
that's me and Larry a collaboration we
were doing uh so but what I really liked
as we all know is the the unlimited
budget of the blank page and you can do
anything you know at home without having
to you know necessarily spend a lot of
money to do it so um so 1985 uh Larry
gets wind from his father Denny that
Howard Chaykin needs an assistant to
work on American flag because I think he
was getting rid of one or somebody was
leaving and then I got all jealous I was
like really like you're gonna go I mean
I'm the guy who really wants to do
comics not you but whatever he was still
into it and then he got wind that next
door bilson cabbage wanted a needed in
the system but i think was more that he
was just jealous at howard had one or
something I don't know so I get there
and I'm like there's no way what I'm
drawing matches anything that bills
doing and and but I wound up working on
a new mutants Electra assassin and doing
some of the backgrounds in and
everything and then but I was hanging
out more with the Howard because bill
was constantly like on the phone with a
therapist or something and just you know
he was getting psychology today I think
he was preparing for straight toasters
or something but uh but i was driving
more with howard and then Walter was in
that room the room next door with James
Sherman is another
cartoonists and previous i think jim
Starlin Frank Miller and some other guys
had been in the studio so I kind of like
hopscotch between bill and Howard and
then eventually worked also with Walter
on the Thor specifically the Frog
stories when Thor became a frog right so
the Frog story huh a lot of tracy's oh
so you yeah that was fun stuff so I mean
but then it was the first time I knew at
age 17 going on 18 that I was among gods
you know like there's an American flag
I'm working on that Thor bill syncovich
you know working on the books he was
working on actually Dennis Cohen and the
guy named Michael Davis moved in with
builtin cabbage so I was surrounded by
these incredible you know storytellers
and storymakers and in fact with guys
and not only were learning or knew how
to collaborate in the franchise comic
system but also you know splitting off
to do their own works you know like with
first comics and and you know these
kinds of independent publishers so I was
getting schooled a lot you know we're
just bye-bye you know proxy just by
being in the room and then they would
pull pranks on me in that kind of stuff
went to the whole nother story but but
that was a year of of real education i
was going to an arts high school that
had not taught me perspective and was
and I would slap my hand if I drew a
comic but then at three o'clock till
about six o'clock I was hopping a train
with Larry O'Neill to learn comics that
was encouraged and teaching me so many
ways to show a story with art in that
one year alone with so much education
you know my mentors because when you
just were saying you know ways of
telling stories and when you just shows
a page of yours um when you were talking
about a contract with God that Eisner
did I know that that was I think before
that there weren't really stories about
immigrants or tea or you know that type
of story something that's talking about
God I mean I may be that that kind of
got the ball rolling in
terms of eventually autobiographical
stories and these kind of these
Universal ideas of things that we all go
through that are very in a way I know
superheroes are have that idea but just
trying to have these commonalities that
that we can talk about in comics that
are very different from superheroes and
I think that that that stories those
stories that Eisner did sort of set that
ball rolling so that people like us you
know today are doing autobiographical
stories and writing about I know miss
was mrs. book talks a lot about really
heavy issues like bulimia and my my own
work also talks about depression and
eating disorders and things that weren't
typically talked about and I think that
that kind of can go back to Eisner and
those early works people that we were
talking about in the east village who
began to set the precedent for a
different type of story that can feed to
hold using words and images no you did
you were very volved in the internet and
the opening days of the internet and
most of your comics have been yeah I've
been I've been doing comics online since
1996 95 is that related to New York and
Silicon Alley and all that um well I was
at that time I was in a program in at
NYU that I teach at now called
interactive telecommunications program
which is just looking at technology and
using technology to do things in
different ways and when I was there I
was interested in comics and when I was
thinking about technology and how can I
tell can't use use the technology to
tell a story in a different way and if
i'm going to use the technology i'm not
going to just have it be that i'm going
to put something online that can be
printed out on a page and i'm going to
really think about presenting my story
in a way that's unique to a to a
computer and this this page is actually
from a book it's the only book i've ever
done and that was two years ago so I've
been doing stuff for since 95 but only
in 2008 today actually go to paper oh
yeah so that's uh JC's all right so yeah
this is New York and I think the
I had just gotten my ears pierced and as
you can see this black and white when I
when I first started doing comics it was
in 95 96 it was Netscape one point 0 and
most people were using modems and if you
wanted your images to be seen quickly
and your target audience for me which
was teenage girls were probably using
the older computer which had even the
worst modem you wanted people to be able
to look at your your images quickly and
so black and white was the easiest way
to do that and that's why I started out
in black and white now it's just that's
that's the style that I'm known for and
that's another scene of you went on when
I was a teenager and I'm just I was I
spent a lot of time in clubs and so I
didn't go to college and did a lot of
stuff in the east village and that's
just I think you wouldn't maybe get that
if you were growing up in the suburb
where you could just go to clubs and be
out until five six in the morning and
then dancing all night and getting your
tattoos and going to piercing clinics
and doing all the things that I did that
are very maybe I don't even know if
they're typical New York but certainly I
don't think you could have done them if
you weren't in a place like New York
City that opportunity to do it the right
way if you have your friend Pierre
series for you so in a way you end up
more of a degenerate right you're
starved for that I had that with the
potato we did those behind here I don't
appear so I just miss so here's a mess
of ever said how was this done in New
York after Pratt or yeah this was done
in New York if I could actually if I
could go back to contract I just wanted
to say that um that really like Eisen or
act it really opened the door to do like
big stories about people who would beat
small people not really literally small
like me but like like small in the sense
of like someone who'd be ignored by an
epic superhero story or even maybe a
more comedic story and just the it's the
neighborhood that I live in I live in
the lower east side and I have been for
the last 16 years so I consider myself a
New Yorker but it's the idea that you
know anyone any given window you look in
there's a story in there well and that's
important too for someone like me to
do the kind of work that I did if there
was no precedent I think it would have
been harder to sell to a publisher well
it was piqued our an influence or a
precedent at all he wasn't an influence
but his the way he changed the the comic
marketplace I think probably helped me
and the people he was an influence on
but I didn't read him until I'd already
done graphic novel but it's the same
idea he was probably pulling from the
same source you know Eisner his
contemporaries did you know about the
spirit was that on your radar at all
eyes mr. spirit only as an adult when I
started to get into ec comics and then
started to look around you know in in
every direction that those people spread
from that was something that I enjoy as
an adult so now this and I tell us about
it so mess of everything is new york
informed oh and at the very end of the
book at the very end of the book i and i
end up in new york and it's about you
know fleeing the suburbs for the city
but even though i did this in New York
this is looking back on the suburbs so I
guess it's because I had the distance of
being in the city you have a clearer
view looking back of you know what was
ridiculous and what was exciting about
the suburbs I commissioned a a new york
story from myth for the series called
next-door neighbor right sorry she tells
a classic story about a neighbor which
but it could only happen well now that's
not true can don't happen to New York
but you know big cities yield these
kinds of stories that you can get but in
the suburbs if you had a neighbor that
was causing that kind of trouble you
just you stay in your house they stay in
their house it's not someone in your
hallway screaming about you know needing
to be let in while they're in their
halloween costume is like a sexy
schoolgirl and now these are not new
york images but when i asked you for New
York inspired our this is among the
things you sent how was New York
inspiration on this I think
just sent the one on the left as an act
of shameless self-promotion I don't
think it actually has to do with New
York well well shamelessly
self-promoting which is a story I'm
working on which is I guess I pictured
his cute animals and religious
fundamentalism but it's actually kind of
in the vein of bone and you know an
adventure story but it's about the
dangers of fundamentalist thinking and
then on the right was kind of a goofy
piece that I did for a podcast anthology
which was exploit explaining where candy
canes come from well let that stuff that
brings me to the end of the slides but I
did want to talk about Dean you I know
have had a couple of different important
internet ventures and Miss has been
other than a Tracy have you been on any
of these internet event as well well ya
know you have your own movie network but
i have my own website and i've had it
since 1996 so it's been pretty much so
has the internet made New York more or
less important in the car tuning world I
think that you know the things that
we've been talking about here in terms
of the inspiration that you get from the
people that you meet or the people that
you don't meet but are wondering about
that's still a very very New York what
the internet does is allows you to to
put up your work and anyone in the world
can see it at any time and that's that's
that's which is in a way kind of a New
York idea that any everyone comes here
and then on the internet everyone is
everyone is there it's funny because I
still think people coming to New York to
see my website but in a weird way and I
just thought of this like because that
question I was like you know as an
artist our cartoonists or a writer
artist of representing New York and
other stories you're an ambassador of
sorts of new york you know because
people using your stories to get an
inkling I listen I want ask Miss I've
never had to come to New York I've
always heard the story of and then I
went to New York I don't know what
that's like you
I'm prime white male and I'm a New
Yorker I'm very privileged me and Louis
CK but do you know I don't think you'd
appreciate it or I would think that that
you all would not appreciate it the same
way someone who has to you know make
their way there I exactly that's got to
be really difficult on the flip side I'm
a cartoonist so I don't get to enjoy the
virtues of New York at least the stuff
that I think the tourists are the people
come to New York or because just too
expensive you know so I've had to learn
how to make a Friday night sitting on a
stoop we're walking around and you know
hang out with some friends and pointing
at people and and you know making fun of
them but that's that's like what I can
afford you know as a cartoonist but then
again by default you get these neighbors
stories and the things that we observe
and and the things we experience and
tell I think also still people are still
coming to New York with what Dean was
saying and so you're still me even
though i think that the internet make
really disperses everything there's
still this where do people go and i
think that still people are coming to
New York and you're meeting those people
and the kind of the creative I exchange
of ideas happens not always online how
it happens when you see people well and
and you know I i co-created and founded
activate this this web comics website in
2006 and then last November created trip
city and I distinctly said it's Brooklyn
filtered because I realized after a
while I you know what am I not
international you know this is where I'm
from so why it might well say it you
know you cross the bridge from manhattan
to brooklyn this morning and very
difficult i'm from here from Manhattan
but yeah i'm i became a brooklynite
somehow I think we have a time for some
questions oh I'm sorry I'm sorry message
I just wanted to say that the the flip
side of the whole coming to New York is
now that I'm a mom and I have a son who
was born here and who's going to be
raised in New Yorker and my husband and
I we find ourselves debating should we
move somewhere else or should we let him
be
no no I raised you where's your husband
from what's it was your husband from
Philly he's a cartoonist to Kevin colden
that's all your film the question is the
kids in our neighborhood are such a
little animals and we were trying to
speculate what our son is going to be
like and you know we don't want him to
do this or do that and so then that
becomes the question and then I point
out people like like Dean I know I was
like well Dean's from New York he's okay
well well al al your alley or city hid
then he went to the suburbs and now
you're back al al you were a city guy
then he went to the suburbs then you
came back so the suburbs not only
cracked up to be well the thing about
New York City that I think affected me
and working for mad the advertising
agencies by and large are pretty heavily
represented in New York and at one time
I think they were only in New York and
the early television also emanated from
New York with NBC and CBS and and others
so are doing the kind of work that I've
done for Mad Magazine all these years I
found that the atmosphere of New York
lent itself a very easily for satirical
material because you were surrounded by
you know advertisements that television
shows that originated here and so so
much of so much of the commercial
activity of the country was emanating
from New York or at least it felt that
way and so you were inundated in this
stuff and it was easy to pick things to
have fun with and I think it influenced
me and
certainly my my friends harvey kurtzman
and will elder and even Jack Davis came
to New York to get started do you think
the work you when you lived in the
suburbs do you think the work you did
was different than the work you do now
that you're back living in the city for
quite a while I i think i think it was i
think my frame of mind tended to see
things for more moral bucolic setting
rather than the you know the rumble of
New York but I moved to New York I moved
back to New York about I don't know 50
years ago or so and so other than I
think I'm I'm a New Yorker now well the
suburbs gave you the suburbs did give
you snappy answers to stupid questions
that can only happen to the suburbs
that's true if you don't mind telling
that story again you want to hear that
again you know I never get tired of it
yeah I think everyone is bored with that
store that will be the judge of that
yeah well I'll gloss over it for those
of you who've heard it on Long Island
everyone when I first moved out there
had an antenna that was attached to the
chimney and periodically God who
apparently did not care for television
too much in those days sent a storm that
would knock the antenna over and we had
a climb up and straighten the antenna I
have a great fear of heights I borrowed
an extension ladder to go up the
equivalent I think of three stories to
get to the top of the chimney and I'm
hugging the chimney because I'm scared
to death
and I'm trying to tighten the steel ring
that's around the chimney and I hear
footsteps on the ladder behind me and as
they approach the voice says where's mom
at this point I said I have killed her
and I'm stuffing her down the chimney
and of course the footsteps rapidly
retreated and my son didn't speak to me
for about two weeks but when you're a
freelance writer or artist your wife
goes out shopping for food or whatever
and if she's not there when the kids
come home the first thing they do is
they want to know where mom is as if you
know you're attached to her all day uh
but when I got down I said you know
there's something here what can I do for
mad with this and i quickly jotted down
a bunch of annoying experiences that
I've had and quickly sketched
illustrations with it brought it in and
it was immediately bought so that's how
that started inauspiciously does anyone
have any questions for the panelists
gene cannon Berg is racing to the
microphone gene gene cannon burn journey
ladies and gentlemen
thank you I how does it out of magazines
such as mad tackle social issues such as
Boeing which may not have a reader
audience but it's a very hot topic these
days what did you say boating bullying
bowling boy balayya in high school Oh
guoliang boy well I was is that is that
question four hours bully that have no
bowling alley you know mad magazine like
all publications and that includes
everything you read or see has to keep
up with the times bullying has been
going on since one cavemen hit another
caveman over the head to steal his
girlfriend well mad in my in the time in
the early days when I was producing a
lot of material format which which I'm
not doing anymore I'm just sort of
limited to the fold in and snappy
answers because I haven't kept up with
bullying but mad mad has to keep up with
what's current and of course it goes too
much younger people who are experiencing
either the effects of bullying or they
are bullies themselves and that's why
they get the straight dope so I'm not
part of the editorial board of mad I'm a
freelance writer artist but I know how
these guys work and they they expect
material to come in that's current and
bullying is is one of the things and
their internet games are another thing
that you know I don't play them but the
readers do so they have to stay on top
of this
this one's also for Al not exactly a
question but maybe it is sort of i
started reading comics when i was a very
young kid and my parents never threw
anything out I was I was very blessed
that way except for one thing I forget
how old I was but I got an issue of Mad
Magazine and there was a fold-out on the
back that I didn't understand you folded
it in and there was like this acronym
that showed up and I didn't know what
that meant I look in the dictionary I
couldn't figure it up so I was late at
night I woke up my mom and said mom
what's VD so and then they throw out my
Mad Magazine so I just wanted to thank
you for that little bit of a pre teen
rebellion that I had he is very good
design thank you anybody else have any
questions I'll come up to the microphone
please how you doing man actually this
is a question for Dina really anyone can
answer it really on the panel but I'm
curious this you've been blogging about
the lives of what making a living as a
cartoonist today now what's it like in
New York now can you speak to that a
little bit about some of these issues
you've been talking about it's tough
yeah yeah in New York but it's obviously
effective apparently it's been tough
though since the beginning of making
comics so it's like why am i crying uh
you know that it's just really tough to
be a freelancer number one forever so
you'd like what Al does and like what I
think a lot of us do is you have to
generate your own work and hopefully
have access to a door that's slightly
ajar and then crack it open I mean for
all intents and purposes the three major
graphic novels i've done between the
quitter with Harvey Pekar Jonathan Ames
with the alcoholic and then Cuban my
revolution within Verna Lopez DC wasn't
coming to me and knocking on my door for
those I went to them and then I you know
got to play with some of their toys
which you know I'm a big fan of
superhero comics I wanted to do that but
then I realized you know I wasn't going
to get the regular monthly gig
and so I had to use the DIY tools that
were presented to us at the time which
is the internet is blogging is you know
you can create your own website and when
people come up to me today they're like
you know how do I do this I'm like I
don't know just show your show up to the
party and on a regular basis that's the
only way that anybody can get through
this you know we'll move to New York but
that's the best that well there's a lot
of people there but maybe it is better
to I mean listen loca many people came
out of Ohio there's a lot of great
cartoons came out Ohio came out they
didn't stay there and and well that's
true but uh you know you don't
necessarily need new york for that III
think there's an energy here that is you
know unmatched um you know the fact that
we can sit in a room with I mean look
many people in the audience we got you
know Paul Levitz chris claremont Peter
Cooper other people have represented New
York and they're in their stories I'm
sure there's a ton of other cartoons
Cliff over there i mean the new york
city talk about breeding you know it's
an infection of sports like it's a it's
a it's the best kind of virus you can
have i think is the fact that is there's
some weird domino effect happening but
uh to cal account um it's just really
difficult and you just gotta stay on top
of things that the way they get you is
that once you're in love with comics
you're always going to probably do
comics no matter how badly they treat
you it that that so if you're aware of
that then you know how to negotiate from
there i think i'd wanted to ask Miss to
a library a little more you started to
talk about what it's like to come to New
York as like a wannabe artists I just
wanted to hear a little more because New
York is both a breeding ground for the
natives who produce but also it's a
magnet so can you talk a little bit more
about you know getting in and finding
your way i would say i initially tried
to continue what i've been doing in
boston which was a horrible way to do
comics which is just i do what i want
and then i bring them to stores on
consignment and then you go back and you
bug them at st. Mark's comics when they
you know accidentally lost the stuff
that they sold and he try and get paid
and eventually I think I started to do
more with Dean's saying where you you
know you you make your own proposals you
do your own pitches and for me
especially because I don't do a
superhero stuff there isn't the
opportunity to really apprentice because
in indie comics most people like the
take is so small at the end of the day
that like you'd be looking for such a
small piece suit would be like like
third-world wages like you'd probably be
better making shoes in China so I think
also just to go back to answer and
Calvin a little bit I think New York
prepares you to survive to hear survivor
whether it's trying to live in New York
City and be a freelancer I mean that's
that's a double-edged sword you know so
I think what it does it really tests you
and challenges you in a way that if you
can get by you're already like winning
in some way least that's why don't you
can get by anywhere yeah well I mean it
was going back to peak are my favorite
moment in american splendor of the movie
is out of an out-of-context moment where
Harvey Pekar is sleeping and having a
nightmare and he wakes up and the only
thing he says is I have a job I have a
job
and I was just like what a brilliant
scene like I hit my heart so much like
wow you know i think i was in cleveland
you have time for one more question hi
thank you so much this is such a
wonderful panel my question well to
preface it I think that what we've seen
here is just the tremendous power of of
stories and being able to tell your own
story and so I draw a lot of inspiration
from that so my question is you know out
of curiosity I wonder if you think that
there are stories that aren't being told
and maybe stories that you would like to
see more of just off the top of your
head thanks you mean New York stories
are in comics right yeah well in a weird
way I mean al you've made a career out
of the two major things that people know
before but do you ever wanted to do a
full auto bio story or tell someone
else's story a new york story or I I
thought about doing something
autobiographical and as a matter of fact
I was I was working with a publisher on
the idea but it was very slow and coming
so my friend Mary Lou Weisman came to me
one day we met actually we were chatting
and she's she decided that she would
like to do an article about me and then
she wrote my she decided that you want
to extend it into my biography so that
kind of short-circuited my well you did
75 new illustrations for the dot Martin
you did 75 new illustrations for the
biography
so yeah I didn't it did the
illustrations for it but on sale here it
would have been it would have been fun
although I probably would have taken a
rest of my life to to do a a you know a
graphic novel you know where you have
dialogue and you know and in this case
over dialogue was was in text form and I
just put an illustration there which was
a lot easier but years ago when I
thought of of the idea the first thought
that occurred to me is it who would be
interested in asian like that I mean
it's my personal story i'm interested
why would any old anyone else be
interested but I've been proven wrong by
all the successful you know examples
anybody else I think I think I'm being
told to wrap it up so thank you
everybody thank you everybody